うーんこんにちははじめ雪です挿し芽にドン気に入ったんですけどもどれくらいのは1
か月前くらいに行ったんですけどもやっぱりドンっていいですね
ドンキのおもちゃコーナー欠席でいつも見ちゃうんですけども今回はなかなか面白そう
なロボットを見つけましたこちら
サウンドセンサーロボット結構小さめのロボットなんですけどもうなんかすごいんです
よね思うんとかで何かモノを張っ
飛んできたに長くなんかお前何して部分やつって何を撮ったり
風大暴走してますねフレーズ開けてみましょう要するにてな音とかに反応するロボット
で見ての通りをボンドコップがあるんでロボットがコーチらで持ってきたりするんじゃ
ないかなっていう気はしています
実際どうかわかんないけどねバランス抜群かわいい配膳ロボットってくれてるからを
育てなんか凡打を持っていけるんじゃないかなという程度開けます
ああああああ
どういうこれ大丈夫かする電池単三3つでサイト上で完成しました早速動かしてみ
ましょう
これ説明書が何も入ってなかったからちょっとも量が著しく少ないんだよな
不可解すぎる
どんな機能があると儲からないし
で尿にしたよあっているので全部あってます
する2
んはぁっ
俺は
この曲を聴いた瞬間
あの夏を思い出したった
yeah
[拍手]
あーそっと待って急すぎるを色々と負け話で待って話し聞いてこんな島で北1条
なって混ぜまってなんで被災地上のサバンナの曲だと異性がすごいいいんですけど
また音にかかっ
夏まで何もちゃんとなんかマジか
ちょっと
ちらーっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ちょっとイマイチわからんだねこれどういうことサウンドセンサーで自動に動く
光る音楽が鳴るそこはわかったんですけどもう勝手に変えがもう被災して情報音楽動い
てるだけで僕は何を誰に完走することができません音に反応するって書いてあるんです
けど完全にて美容師は知ってるね何かしらて多分くるのかなって予想してみませんか
今のところからですからねこの箱とかって良かったこと一切衆生と様ちぇるぐらいです
からねええ
ああああああああ
まだ弟弟こっちゃうって怒ってる男杖お得
いっ
ありがとう他のものを運ぶ時に1歳市場のサバを口ずさみながらくると積極としては
決して言いたいことは言えないのであんまりサービスはよくないかなっていう気を示す
猫の配膳ロボットはこんなこともあろうかと音で動くであろうロボットたくさん買って
あげました人がどんどん家久石譲の summer だけかどうかっていうのなんか
みんな違う音だけかもしれないして多分 greeeen のキセキとか歌ってくれる
奴もいるんだと思います
1回全員確かめてみようしょうちゃんどうとかなるか
[音楽]
music したと
[拍手]
お前も一切しそうかやばいな二人共に際し増でしたね3人目
これを絶対でいい第4条 music start
[拍手]
というわけで全部開けてみたんですけども前久石譲でしたそれでこの商品の謎を一つ
ときました曲を全部統一して最終情報様です後はほんとねーたんのセンサーで自動二国
っていうのがファンは死んでも風ていただいてますかなぁて去っパクトどう反応するか
が分からない
近くまで来てくれるとも交えてないから音に反応としか書いてないのでどのレベル
ってどういう意味の音が感動するのかがちょっと書いてないですね
も意味がわかんないし机と撃っちゃう熱情で確認してみよう
[拍手]
[音楽]
ガービザ担当です何なんなになるほどな音に反応ってそういうことか
ひょっとして元が止まってから僕が何か話しかけるとまたし大市場であるというそう
いうことかもしれない多分
me
なるほどねそういうことがわかった音が鳴ると再び動きだって意味の音に反応という
意味ですね
なるほどなるほど追ってを受け8日に行う
[音楽]
re
もうすごいなぁなるほどながらのん
ええええええ
すごいですよね
ran
[拍手]
[音楽]
バンバンで持って待ってああああ
あああん
deji
info works haaaan
[音楽]
pandan